c'est devenu presque banal de les voir
dans les villages côtoyer la vie normale
des soldats l'épicerie des chars et
désabusé à la gare des jeunes hommes en
uniforme qui eux seuls connaissent leurs
ordres ou attendre de les recevoir nous
sommes à paul collier à 50 kilomètres de
la frontière et le chemin de fer mène
tout droit vers les territoires de
donetsk et de louga tu
pendant que le soleil se couche et ici à
moscou la douma franchissait un pas de
plus vers le scénario de guerre d'avoir
trois
présidents en donnant officiellement au
président de l'adir poutine le feu vert
officiel pour qu'il envoie l'armée dans
ces enclaves de l'ukraine mais dans les
faits les troupes russes sont déjà
arrivés et la population célèbre
ben nous on est content
pour nous c'est la protection il faut se
rabattre sur les vidéos et les
témoignages de résidents que nous
connaissons à de nettes comme vous êtes
l'anah pour savoir ce qui se passe
depuis 24 heures qu'est-ce que vous
souhaiter pour les prochains jours que
le cren nos l'on nous laisse tranquille
c'est ce qu'on a toujours demandé
c'est à dire l'autonomie une fois pour
toutes mais jusqu'où exactement au delà
de la ligne de front et à quel prix
le reconnaître konami 2
en forme actuelle
les reconnaître sous leur forme
historique c'est-à-dire comprend des
en tout contrôler
mario roy
lors d'un point de presse complètement
inattendu et provocateur tard ce soir le
président a confirmé nos mesures prises
neil qu'il reconnaît l'ensemble de la
région tels les deux communes peuvent
donc justifiée il postule
une déclaration qui ne laisse aucun
doute sur les risques d'une invasion
majeur
s'il se dit même prêt à démilitariser
l'ukraine pour protéger son pays dans
les villes limitrophes comme portes
closes ce collier ou l'armée russe se
préparent les résidents s'inquiètent de
la catastrophe en devenir chez leurs
voisins américains
amélie comme nova tant mieux car c'est
la faute des américains
ce sont eux qui possèdent ukrainien vers
nos frontières du olga sa voisine marie
a dit qu'elle est terrifiée et croit
poutine a tort de défendre des
soi-disant russe de l'autre côté de la
frontière en octobre au stade est beau
c'est nous le peuple qui allons souffrir
des sanctions président ion d'un du
pilote se trouvaient le président
poutine et les proches du pouvoir maria
dit qu'elle s'était réjoui comme
beaucoup d'autres russe de l'annexion de
la crimée en 2014
mais le dôme base en ukraine dit elle il
n'en vaut pas la peine
la vérité est que si vladimir poutine a
réussi à reprendre la crimée sans tirer
un seul coup de feu en 2014
le sort de l'ukraine en 2022 pourrait
être tristement différent ici tamar
altérait secours aide au canada à pau
clough skier en russie